well this is what great leaders do
whether it's presidents or leaders of
companies steve jobs i would argue musk
is that way
is to walk into a room full of people
who don't want you to create drama
it's weird man when people just kind of
want to be nice
the niceness creates momentum and nobody
wants to
it's the systems thing everybody just
behaves in the way they were
previously behaving in the way they're
supposed to behave
and nobody wants to raise a fuss it
takes a great
man or woman leader to step in and say
what we've been doing
is okay you're fired you're
fight you're cool what is it that right
i'm out yeah i i think you have to
create
constant revolutions within a company
that's very very difficult to do
structurally and psychologically it's
very difficult to do
to to be able to sort of yeah to
constantly
challenge the way things have been done
in the past and
which is why another way it's often done
is a startup like a small company
basically a small company becomes really
successful and then no longer can
turn the ship so a new startup comes
along right a new competitor
that then challenges the big ship and
then that starts out the winner that's
like google came to be
saw twitter came to be in facebook and
so on
and uh apple has you know that that was
the dream
of steve jobs as it would succeed for
for many decades for like centuries
that was the idea that you would keep
keep creating revolutions and
under steve jobs apple successfully
pivoted a bunch of times
right just like reinvented themselves
which is funny very difficult to do
because i mean i've heard at least i
don't know if this is accurate because i
wouldn't know anything but i've heard
plenty of people
complain about steve jobs yeah but
in reality the reason that all of these
amazing things were done was because
this person was willing to
obviously brilliant and then also
willing to to rattle the you know rattle
everyone's cage periodically and say hey
what's going on
is not what we need to be doing that's a
really interesting thing so he would
rattle
the cage but he would also i don't know
if those are
intricately connected or always have to
be connected but he would just be a dick
so maybe by my maybe by his standard i
am lazy and worthless
well is he being a dick though if by his
standard i mean like again it's like
everyone's stupid compared to somebody
you know i guess uh but so you you
apparently are able to take that kind of
thing it's
uh sometimes you just
you caught there's there's ways to cross
the line and i mean this is
okay the the fascinating thing about
being a leader
especially leader of companies is it's a
people problem
so each individual in a room so
as a leader you're only really
interacting with a small number of
people because there are leaders of
other smaller groups and so on
but each of those individuals in the
room have their own different psychology
some like to be pushed to the limits
some some like
like to be screamed at some have
are very soft spoken and almost afraid
to speak and they have to be
uh you have to you have to hear them out
like there's a
and those those could be all superstars
we're not we're not talking about like
the c students we're not talking about
the
students well it's funny that yeah but
the thing to me the skill to manage all
of those people is completely separate
from the skill to innovate something
i mean not that they're not connected
but it's funny how it's it's almost like
uh you know why do we have
shitty why do we have shitty
representatives yeah well i mean the
thing that you do to get elected has
nothing to do with governance yes yeah
also
well that's exactly it but the the great
leaders have to have both skills
so like you have to have the boldness of
maybe if you look at the great
presidents through history
you know usually in a time of crisis is
when they step up
but they basically say okay stop this
old way that congress works of this
bickering of this like
compromise here's a huge plan
that cost
billions of dollars in today's age
trillions of dollars
no extra pork no extra additions just
like here's a clear plan
we're going to build the best road
network
the the world has ever seen and we're
going to build some huge infrastructure
project we're going to
revolutionize internet or we're going to
for coronavirus
we're going to build the largest like
testing facility the world has ever seen
in terms of the
we're going to get everybody tested uh
several times a day
all those kinds of things huge projects
and say uh
all this uh the details that
everybody's bickering about we're gonna
give everybody uh
two thousand dollars and give everybody
three thousand dollars like huge
projects
and at the same time so that's the
boldness and the leadership and saying
throw out all the of the past
and at the same time be able to get in
the
room with the leaders of both parties
over the powerful individuals
and smooth talk the out of them in
the way they need to be smooth talk to
so like both of those skills it seems to
when they're combined in one person
that's
that creates great leaders musk appears
to have that elon
i don't know if steve jobs it's
interesting so the criticism of steve
and a little bit on elon is he misses
some of the human
part um but maybe it's impossible to
have a really
uh you have like signia nadal who's the
ceo of microsoft you have um
who's really good on the human side
really really good on the human side
like everybody loves them
uh the ceo of uh google alphabet
uh is also the same way so like i don't
know if it's possible to have both
uh you only get so many stat points yeah
you're only
in this in this rpg of life yeah
you